[Music]
what did you think of the data set
yeah very wordy
i was like what am i gonna do with this
i mean like i thought it's something
it's totally like not too much analysis
it's kind of like
there's some interesting words here
let's just feature some words
okay yeah
do you want to see it i do want to see i
want to okay yeah absolutely i'm also
curious if we did the same thing yeah i
mean like
i approach this like
let's just like get a bunch of words and
show me some long words and some short
words and give me some definitions it's
really fun because like i was able to
like find a package wait what
a different package that defines words
uh it's called dictionary with uh
capital r somewhere dictionary define
i was like that's kind of sweet you know
what they do they uh they actually have
like they use an api like they hid an
api somewhere okay and they're able to
get like audio as well like audio links
so i thought let's put some audio in
this table
this table can speak to you
i mean tables always speak to me but
this one can actually speak to you okay
so i want to do what i want to do is get
like the types of words and these are
like long and short words basically um
i'm sometimes impressed with very long
words like well yeah about 15 percent
yeah and there's some words like
i don't have rants like i would like to
see them pronounced so this is actually
quite nice
so what i'm doing here is like this this
will show me like random words it'll
just pick from like those you know giant
word lists from those crossword puzzles
okay and give me like five long words
give me five short words define them
it's almost like word of the day times
five what time yeah actually
yeah yeah so it's good so what i did was
like okay so i got the uh you know as i
did before in the last table battle i
just sourced like uh all the reading of
like you know the tables
i basically just ignored all the columns
except
this is so bad for thai tuesday like
ignore everything
uh and basically i just got like all the
words
and then i did some cleanup as i often
do um
you know made everything lowercase you
know nice sorted the long words from the
short words and then i hit this api
which was you know given to you by this
dictionary okay is it is it i just
searched for like you know a grant
package that would be like you know
offered me some definitions and this is
like a three-star package that deserves
more than speed stars so if you see a
dictionary around
give it more stars yeah yeah like it you
it does a lot um this is some work here
yeah yeah so i had to do a heck of a lot
of stuff because like sometimes i just
give you like weird
outputs so i had to like do some
pretty wild stuff to make it like work
like this all this stuff
so ignore this this is just basically
just trying to like fish out like one
like uh pronunciation like fanatic
conversation out of like possibly like a
list
which may be empty so i
had to go through all this and then
finally i get the audio link
and here's a cool thing so i finally get
to my gt table
okay another thing i noticed um the api
hits doesn't always give you like a lot
sometimes words don't
so basically what i do is i get 40 words
and then i store them
in terms of like what it offers in terms
of metadata like that's all this stuff
and then i sort them and just get the
cream of the crop as it were you know
like obviously descend by the score
slice the head
and then i get like a you know like
words with
you know some stuff to them like you
know it has some media like the
pronunciation i did the same thing as
last time i uh i made columns with like
i defined the widths
here's a really cool thing you can like
in most browsers well all browsers circa
a long time you could now like use an
audio tag
and you can provide the url which is
what dictionary that our package does i
need to just wrap like the url inside
these tags
and then you get like you know it's
playable you get like this little like
audio player
okay in your freaking table okay so i'm
going to show you this and like there's
some cases where you don't have audio so
i can do this basically to make it work
okay uh eventually gets to the end i'm
going to show you this table
or this function really show me words i
can choose from
times or
so here we go with times it takes like a
few seconds because it's doing some
querying like
okay do some api stuff okay here we go
here we go here's a selection of words
both long and short and uh yeah so it's
sorted by long words
short words and here check it out right
here this is where you get audio see
sometimes you don't get the audio yeah
disappointing sometimes you just just
bad luck okay hopefully this works well
here's here are some beans here we go
beans
you heard that yes you heard that okay
awesome awesome
steel okay i know these words i know i'm
gonna do this again basically rolling
the dice one more time maybe a big dab
will provide
we got some we got some hits uh just
proportion here we go disproportion
degeneration same person
same
yeah
oh we've got a long word aficionado
oh
drake is a male duck
drink
i don't know that i knew that
what is feet shoe
fish
oh well it's a scarf
now i know okay patrol how they
pronounce patrol patrol
patrol
yeah i mean like this it's got some
british issues going on but yeah like
this is this is the following word
it's amazing
yeah this is what i did i didn't
this is what i this is my like my little
twist
this could be
a shiny app
yeah it could be in a shiny app i think
for word a day
oh yeah of course yeah because it's a
function and it just produces a table
it's got like a height which
i think i control because what i did is
i also set the height um not so easy to
do in a table if you have like overflow
so you have to sort of set it a bit
beyond what you expect okay uh there's
probably a way to really fix it with
overflow stuff but
i always can't figure it out and
like 10 stack overflow searches later i
just gave up uh but i did this line
height and then max height at night
and then
maybe this does something
um
it was actually why
i mean anyways this is what i feel about
overflow like i use it sometimes and i
think it fixes the problem but i'm not
confident yeah yeah you really gotta
experiment like in the uh sort of like
the uh the dev tools so add a bunch of
css um
and again i'll just review this one more
time uh if you do that it's really
vitally important that you set the id on
the table
right here in gt
and then once you do that the reason why
you do that is because um
well so you have like a you know some
document with a bunch of tables on it uh
you just want to set the the
typically you just want to set like the
uh the css for the one table you're
focusing on and not for every other
table so it just protects against like
you know multiple tables
yeah so if you didn't have this it would
just be like
maybe that's good maybe that's bad but i
just figured it's better
yeah so these are my functions so just
proving that you can make tables from
functions and it's not that bad
so like you i was very much
um
we're not getting tables with with data
or number there's data but we're getting
so far we've hit nas and then text data
yes so what i thought i would do is play
around a little bit with tidy text from
julia silke and dave robinson excellent
idea so like
get sentiment for these words right
that's exactly what the overall
sentiment yeah yeah so i was like well
what's a good way to group things that's
not
too
um large like i don't want like this
massive table so i was like okay do i
want to do the clue or the answer and i
went with the answer because i didn't
want to like strip out all of the
numbers and i just didn't
and then also does the answer or if
you're using the clue i was like i don't
know that that gives you a sentiment
because the clues are often plays on
words yeah yeah knows that they're
really like
like
i don't think you ever get into these
puzzles i mean i know a lot of people
that do
yeah like wow it takes it takes a while
to get into it
these are tough
yeah some of these are hard so i was
like you know i played around with it a
little got to use a little lubridate um
which is always fun so converting the
numeric i just wanted the month and then
i essentially went through i did have
some n a dates so i just dropped those
um i'm definitely a just get rid of the
n a values defaults sorry to everyone
out there who does not believe in that
that's a good idea um
and then i what did i do yeah so i did
that and then i kind of played around
with things um and i just used so julia
and dave
recommend three libraries and this is
from tidy text um so i just went with
one of them and i did a little join
and got a nice little actually let's run
some of this
yeah
let's see what we get
running a whole bunch of stuff we don't
need to run and that's fine
so big i didn't know what big dave was
but i read it and then i just i just
worked with the times data you could do
all of them if you wanted but basically
i got the month the word the sentiment
and then the
count like the number of times that it
appeared
so i was like oh okay what i could do is
i can group by um month and then this
combines all the years and then i was
like i could take kind of the number one
negative word and the number one
positive word for each of times see if
times get seasonal effective disorder or
something like that
right with two months there are things
like
negative in january
so i ended up using i was thinking about
how i wanted to do this i arranged it
and then i just did a slice max
um
and then
oh yeah here's like the basic table
so you've got your month your word and
then your sentiment
um
and so i thought that was kind of fun
and then
let's make it look a little nicer so i
went for a black and white theme like a
newspaper that's nice
this is see
basketball yeah i was thinking using
basketball too it seems like such a
a great like writerly font like yeah so
the new york times turns out uses
georgia and georgia is not on google
fonts
i think i have georgia but i was like
we'll do google fonts so it's replicable
for anybody at home doing this yeah
basketball is a total classic i'm glad
there's any version of that
yeah so
did that um
pretty happy with it i couldn't get like
it bothers me that this space is bigger
than this space
um
and so i spent some time like moving
things around and just couldn't
get it where i wanted it
it's tough because like it doesn't
center nicely and then like everything
gets crowded it gets too thin i don't
know it's
yeah it was rough yeah you know made it
work um i thought it was interesting
like
you know how did i what's the best way
to present things because there were a
lot of ties right so february has
multiple ties
um for its you know most positive words
and then it you know like i think
there's something here around like the
spread so almost always you see your
negative word there's always like a
clear negative winner and then like a
spread of positive winners there's never
really um like june abolish an elite
there we go done deal
um but there's oh okay august you see a
lot more negative i don't know what's
happening in august
um people are not as happy in august i
guess
yeah like that that's an angry month
that's what i'm saying
you're either idle or you're a rate
you're going to sack something loose
baby sue you hate litigious too oh my
god
you know september starts to balance out
october you know a little more negative
than positive but so i thought this was
you know and then i've got like my
little source notes in here um
yeah i did not use fantastic
blowing lowering the line i thought of
it later and i was like it's okay
if i were to redo this or if i were to
like keep working on this i was really
curious about doing something where
instead of just looking at the top it
kind of did a full
sum of all the negatives
and then a full sum of all the positives
and then it gave you like a positivity
proportion
so if it was let's take like blue and
orange if it's more positive it's more
blue and like it would somehow color
that'll be interesting like the months
themselves yeah yeah so you could look
at like january and be like oh that's
really orange it's a really angry month
whereas february is blue and you could
like see how that swings so that to me
was like that would be a really
interesting programmatic next step and
then maybe get a sample of like the most
negative words um
or most other good ideas i'm surprised
there's no neutral i guess that's just
the way
that these so it's the one it's the
sentiment library
doesn't have that i guess right yeah so
this sentiment library um
you know and like tidy text
my name is the great book yeah it goes
into like the all of the things that you
need to think about when you do this
kind of work but it is just um
i think that it is just positive or not
like that's it it's a very dichotomous
yeah that's right
speaking of table design i love what you
did with doing away with the column
labels totally not needed it's obvious
what's going on here and you just you
just use like the uh the group labels
too like
yeah
did that that was
let me go in here um
i just dropped them
by putting them in his blanks oh perfect
that's good because space which is nice
yeah yeah so you get a little space here
and then i thought about like oh like
decorative borders and i was like no
it's almost like a newspaper column yeah
that's what i'm seeing here that's the
vibe i get totally
[Music]